Uầy không thấy có người xem n đã có một
like rồi định thật Chào
bạn chắc chắn là tôi không tự live cho
tôi Ui hai like luôn đình
thật các bạn live trước à thô tôi nói
thế không phải kêu gọi live đâu Mấy ngồi
live n đại mấy ông ngồi kiểu Ấn thích
cũng chẳng để làm gì cả vì tôi cũng ẩn
ẩn số lượng live mà Chào bạn
Ờ hôm nay thực ra theo tiê đề thì đáng
đáng lẽ Đáng lẽ là mình định vẫn dậy
tiếp à Chính xác là kiểu ngồi livestream
ngồi live code tiếp cái dự án nhưng mà
hôm nay đúng là cũng hơi mệt dạo này tôi
đang đang học cách
kiểu cân bằng lại vì mọi khi thì tôi có
nói mấy ông ấy là tôi làm buổi sáng xong
rồi buổi tối này sẽ về tranh thù ngủ
nhanh một tí để mà tối có sức mà còn
livestream như này nhưng mà nó khá là
hại điểm là mình ngủ thế xong ngồi tối
nó bị kiểu khó ngủ ấy nên là gần đây là
tôi đã học cách kiểu nói chung là phải
sinh hoạt Ừ Cả ngày Xõa đi kiểu C thế để
cho tối kiểu mệt xõa người để mệt giã
người ấ để mà tối ngủ ngủ sâu ngủ ngon
các thứ và ban ngày thì mình phải tỉnh
táo còn đấy Nói chung là về tối sẽ ngủ
được nên thành ra
là chưa quen được với cái giờ giấc đấy
không ạ Nên là buổi tối này đang vẫn
chưa t đủ tỉnh táo nhưng mà buổi hôm nay
tôi vẫn sẽ chữa bài kiểu hỗ trợ các bạn
chữa trả lời vài câu hỏi tâm sự xong rồi
có bạn cũng hỏi hỏi về thiết kế cơ sở
liệu thì tôi sẽ hỗ trợ bạn đấy để giải
đáp còn về live code thì chắc là buổi
sau thì mình H vọng có thể thì mình sẽ
nv không ạ tự Dương bản update vs code
không hiển thị nv
nữa tôi không thể mở vs code nv bây giờ
được vì nó Phả khá nhạy cảm đúng không
nhở
nv bình thường không vấn đề gì
cả Chắc là của em em em thử hỏi anh anh
cá nhân Anh ấy thì đôi khi anh sẽ hỏi C
pilot này vì rõ ràng copilot này là của
Microsoft nó nó sẽ phải chuyên về vs
code theo theo như mình muốn nó là như
thế Theo mình hiểu nó như thế Như Đôi
Khi hỏi mấy câu chat VT nó trả lời nó
còn chuẩn
thức nó cập nhật đến thời gian bao nhiêu
nhưng mà đại khái thì tôi thấy CHT Hiện
tại vẫn đang kiểu CHT đương nhiên là nó
lấy nguồn thì cũng từ ngoài trên
internet thôi nhưng mà có vẻ là nó bám
sát
hơn ờ đây tôi hỏi bằng tiếng Anh đấy nhá
là gì nhỉ Đấy thì buổi hôm nay chắc là
tôi sẽ tâm sự một tí sau đó thì tí chữa
bài cho đầu tiên thì có bạn hỏi về thiết
kế cơ sở liệu cho web bán hàng với đặc
biệt là bạn bảo là cái quán bạn cũng hỏi
trên discord này về quán ca phê chẳng
hạn ô Vừ mới tạo thêm một cái vụ l lên
kèo Tìm team giao lưu larel tại sò kìa Ồ
tí tôi duyệt bàn này xem thế nào
Ok thì gi tâm sự mỏng một tí trước đúng
không ạ
Ừ hôm trước nói chung là Ờ tôi cũng sẽ
phải cân nhắc và việc là là những cái
buổi mà mình tâm sự như này hồi trước
thì tôi thường hay bảo là mình sẽ tâm sự
buổi cái cái hồi đầu ấy thì là tâm sự ở
cuối buổi để cho các bạn hiểu được là ví
dụ có nhiều bạn thì muốn xem dạy học thì
bạn đấy sẽ xem ở đầu video xu cuối video
thì có thể bạn không quan tâm lắm
đấy nghĩa là có những người mà theo dõi
kênh tôi đúng kiểu để học thật thì người
ta sẽ lại phải thường hay phải tua ấy
phải tua qua những cái đoạn tâm sự gì gì
đó
Ờ còn có những người chỉ muốn nghe tâm
sự thì chắc là đấy thì tôi đang nghĩ
phải tách hẳn buổi ra Tâm sự riêng nhưng
mà Đúng là hướng của kênh thì đúng là
chắc là tâm sự nhiều hơn về dạy hay thứ
thứ nó sẽ chỉ chia sẻ h th mang thên
hướng về chia sẻ nhiều hơn chia sẻ về
mọi thứ đấy không phải về M
code như Nói chung là tôi sẽ Nên hồi
trước là tôi sẽ thường hay làm cái mục
lục nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là cũng hơi
lười để thường xuyên chỉnh sửa rồi Cập
nhật cái mục lục đấy Nên là hơi khó nhỉ
Ừ Nói chung là cái đấy rất là khó vì có
rất nhiều người từng hỏi tôi những câu
mà tôi trả lời rồi Tôi cũng muốn là kiểu
gửi lại cho họ mấy cái kiểu đoạn mà tôi
đã trả lời
ho về sau phải cắt só ra kiểu cắt só ra
để m gửi kiểu đăng lại xong rồi có ai
hỏi gì mình sẽ gửi qua cái só Đấy cũng
là một
cách Ok Thế nên bây giờ cứ tranh thủ tâm
sự trước thỉnh thoảng là những cái mà
tôi ghi này này thường là tôi đi đường
hoặ tôi kiểu thường chủ yếu nhất là đi
đường à tôi sẽ kiểu suy nghĩ khá nhiều
về mọi thứ Nên là tôi nhớ được cái gì
tôi sẽ ghi nốt lại nhanh nhanh nghe nó
kiểu hơi đôi khi hơi bị
để nắm lợi thế tôi nhớ là cái lúc tôi
ghi câu này là kiểu
nhớ không lầm nó liên quan đến bài toán
kinh doanh
Ờ kiểu khi mà có một cái gì đó mà kiểu
ví dụ Giả sử cái doanh nghiệp của các
bạn đang gặp vấn đề gì gì
đó thì nhiều người sẽ kiểu bỏ cuộc nhiều
người từ bỏ để mà chuyển sang làm cái
khác nhưng mà nhiều người sẽ tận dụng
chính cái cái mà mình mình gặp khó bất
lợi đấy rồi nảy ra một ý tưởng kinh
doanh khác đấy để kinh doanh chính cái
bất lợi đấy vì cảm thấy là mình gặp bất
lợi này thì mấy thằng khác cũng gặp bất
lợi giống mình nếu mà nó theo Giống mình
hồi trước đấy đầu tiên mình học hỏi xem
là những cái thằng kia nó đối mặt với
cái vấn đề này như thế nào nó có gặp vấn
đề này không đúng không ạ Nếu nếu mà giả
sử nó cũng gặp cái vấn đề đấy đúng không
Ok Thế lại một bài toán kinh doanh của
mình ra đây rồi đúng không Nghĩa là hồi
trước thì mình có đối thủ cạnh tranh
đúng không là kiểu tất cả tất cả mấy ông
cùng làm một thứ đúng không Thế bây giờ
mình sẽ mà rõ ràng là mình gặp vấn đề
này mà mình chưa tìm thấy mình chưa tìm
ra được giải pháp chứng tỏ là chưa ông
nào làm ra cái giải pháp cho cái vấn đề
đấy cả đấy xong mình sẽ tìm hiểu xem thị
trường là mấy cái thằng đối thủ Hồi
trước mình ấy nó cũng có gặp vấn đề
không có đúng không Ok Thế mình sẽ mình
sẽ bán giải pháp giải quyết vấn đề đấy
cho nó đấy Kiểu th Khi mà mình mình mà
giải quyết được vấn đề các thử th mớ Ông
hiểu ý tưởng tôi không ạ Đấy vậy tôi có
nghĩ vụ đấy tôi nhớ cái vụ đấy là cái vụ
gì ý Không nhớ về cái ví dụ lắm nhưng mà
Mấy ông hình dùng ý tưởng đúng không Đấy
đương nhiên là nếu mà mình nghĩ ra được
cách giải quát giải pháp để xử lý được
vấn đề đấy thì lại tốt quá đúng không th
tự mình có thể xử lý cho mình nhưng mà
trước mắt thì mình còn xử lý được cho
rất nhiều thằng nữa và mình cũng biến
thành kiểu đang từ mấy thằng đối thủ kia
mình Lã biến thành cộng tác Nói chung là
hồi trước có cái câu gì nhỉ Không có ai
là đối thủ mãi mãi à à Không có kẻ thù
mãi mãi đúng không vân
vân hai anh Hiện em đang làm về mảng qa
autotest Em đang làm với cum l gì gì đó
Anh có thể chia sẻ kinh nghiệm về mảng
này được không ạ
Ờ đặc sáng Tây Bắc
Ờ tôi không biết về mảng này lắm về cảm
bề mảng thế T không nắm rõ lắm Ờ tôi
nghĩ là bạn tra root m của tester để mà
kiểu định hướng dần mình cần phải làm
những gì Và nếu mà có tiền bố đi trước
chuyên V mảng đấy tốt hơn chứ Còn chứ
còn hỏi về hỏi tôi tôi dân đép thì khó
mà trả lời câu đấy
được hỏi tôi về kiến thức chuyên ngành
thì tôi sẽ hỗ trợ được bạn bạn cứ hỏi
trong cộng đồng các thứ nên tham gia
những cộng đồng mà mà nó có thể
kiểu nói chung là bạn phải đi tìm kiếm
bởi vì rõ ràng là bây giờ các bạn hoàn
toàn là tìm trên mạng đầy mà đầy những
cộng đồng kiểu nó cũng đang làm giống
mình tôi nghĩ là có nhưng mà đương nhiên
là để gặp được những người có kiểu người
ta còn muốn chia sẻ và muốn giúp đỡ mình
hay không thì nó là một câu chuyện khác
nữa mình cũng phải thể hiện mình là mình
có một cái gì đó để nó mối quan hệ đôi
bên cù có lợi chứ nếu mà mình mà kiểu
dạng Ừ thì người ta cố gắng mãi người ta
mới được như bây giờ chưa chắc người ta
muốn chia sẻ cái miếng cơm đấy cho mình
đúng không Bởi vì chia sẻ mình là họ là
mình cũng có thể cạnh tranh với họ đúng
không nên mình phải thể hiện sao cho mà
nó triện chím một tí đúng
không đi học khác đi làm rất nhiều nhiều
lúc thấy đuối quá đúng cũng sự thật là
kiểu Tôi cũng thường hay khuyên sinh
viên như thế các bạn có thể thấy bây giờ
đang khó khăn nhưng mà đấy là cái khó
khăn gọi là rất là bé nhỏ phải nói bé
nhỏ Nếu mà ra ngoài đời đúng không ngoài
thực
tế thì bây giờ các bạn chỉ có một mối lo
là kiểu ăn à Chơi xong rồi cũng đ mà
kiểu đi học điểm số các thứ chứ chứ kiểu
dạng
mà ngoài ra ngoài chẳng ai có thể hỗ trợ
mình Các th thứ nữa tự l mình cánh sinh
mình không Mình không làm thì chết đói
Vân Vân đúng không rất nhiều thứ lúc đấy
thì m rất nhiều người ước quay trở lại
gế trường học đúng
không nên là nói chung là tôi Tôi nghĩ
là ngay từ trên cái nhà trường mình mà
đi thực tập sớm mình kiểu va đời sớm ấy
thì mình trân trọng cái khoảng thời gian
đi học kinh khủng luôn Mình sẽ thấy là
ôi kiểu nói chung là không những là trân
trọng khoảng thời gian học trân trọng
tiền đi học rất nhiều người là đng học
phí các thứ thứ có thể là nói chung là
mỗi người mỗi hoàn cảnh thôi nhưng mà
tôi cảm thấy là nhiều người không trân
trọng với cái tiền học đấy lắm chứ chứ
không thì rất nhiều người sẽ sót đúng
không học phí nó nó nó
cũng cũng không rẻ nữa kể cả cho dù là
trường công trường tư tôi không nói nhá
kể cả trường công Bây giờ học phí nó
cũng học phí rồi Thậm chí còn phải học
lại thi lại các thứ đúng
gian này
là nó cũng đặc biệt nó còn cạnh tranh
vân vân nữa nhở hơi
khó mới không nghe được tiếng quạt không
Tôi mở quạt tản nhiệt lên tí cho nó Máy
bớt nóng nó máy Windows mà thí là nó
không thể luôn mát được thoải mái như
máy má nghe được tiếng chắc có nghe thấy
à th được
chưa thấy chưa Con nghe đ không bây giờ
chắc có nghe được tiếng Anh nói đúng
không Nhưng không nghe được tiếng quạt
mà đúng không Alo
Alo Alo
Engineer
mà năm nay chương kiếm được
job càng học càng thiếu thì đúng càng
học càng thiếu thì chứng tỏ là bạn có
nang đi đúng chứ nếu mà càng học càng
nghĩ mình giỏi vãi trưởng mà bên bên
khác không tuyển mình thì có khi đang
học sai hướng không vấn đề gì cả điều
kiện thì ngày càng khó
khăn nên đi tiếp hay không
Ờ không đi tiếp thì bây giờ bạn sẽ làm
gì đã quan trọng là hồi trước giống như
là mấy cái video tôi chia sẻ V của anh
Độ hay là anh b men nói th ra là đôi khi
là phải phải hỏi những cái câu thực tế C
phũ phảng thế đó là các bạn không học
các bạn không theo cái đấy thì các bạn
định làm gì đúng không các bạn sẽ làm gì
tiếp theo các bạn theo được những cái
khác không giống như hồi trước tôi bảo
là tôi năm nhất tôi đi thc Tôi đi làm
thử những cái công việc khác ấy và tôi
cảm thấy là tôi không phù hợp với mấy
cái công việc đấy Nên là Bây giờ tôi chỉ
xác định là cắm đầu cầm đâu Kiểu đâm
theo la đến cùng và công việc này nó là
một gần như là canh bạc cuối kiểu mình
dốc hết mọi thứ ô in vào nó chứ chứ
còn Chứ tôi lúc đấy Tôi không thể nghĩ
việc là lùi bước hay là chọn một con
đường khác được cảm thấy mấy công việc
khác không phù hợp đấy Bây giờ bạn bạn
phải xác định xem là thứ nhất là cái nào
phù hợp với mình cái nào mà kiểu phù hợp
với mình nhá Có có thể là xã hội nó đang
hơi kén chọn có thể là chưa cần mình cho
lắm nhưng mà cái đấy là cái phù hợp nhất
với mình rồi đúng không Thì phải theo
thôi và phải chứng tỏ cho mọi người Kiểu
kiểu gì cũng sẽ có người nhìn ra được
cái sự phù hợp mình và mình sẽ cố gắng
để bướt phá chứ Nếu mà bây giờ bạn chọn
một công việc khác có thể hiện tại xã
hội đang tuyển
đấy nhưng mà vậ bởi vì bạn không phù hợp
với nó thì kiểu gì về sau bạn sẽ lại bị
đào thải đấy Xong rồi lúc đấy thì bạn
lại lúc đấy mới gọi là khó hơn việc mà
bạn quay đầu lại cái cũ Bởi vì bây giờ
bạn đang học nử chừng Bạn làm công việc
khác một chuyên ngành hoàn toàn khác so
rồi về sau bạn quay lại cái này nó khó
hơn rất nhiều đúng không ạ hãy nghĩ nghĩ
kỹ cái đấy đúng không nên là bạn kiểu gì
bạn vẫn nên chọn một cái công việc mà nó
tương đối phù hợp với bạn không phải nói
là phù hợp ở đây là sở thích hay mọi thứ
nhá mà mà chính xác là phù hợp ở đây là
bạn có thể kiểu cầy được nó một ngày
phải 6 đến 8 tiếng mỗi ngày được không
đúng không
không chắc có thể wib giống tôi kiểu
chân nh tay mềm x rồi Kiểu ch không lao
động kiểu lao động nặng được đấy Kiểu
thế thì có rất nhiều công việc nó không
phù hợp với mình Mình quen ngồi máy tính
rồi chẳng hạn đấy
thì thì mình kiểu Nếu mà tận dụng được
những công việc nào đó mà cũng kiểu làm
kiểu môi trường kiểu như thế được thì
tốt tự nhiên bây giờ bảo mình làm công
việc khác thì mình sẽ khoảng thời gian
là mình đuối thôi mình chán nản Vân Vân
Vân lúc đấy thì lúc đấy mình tự nhiên
mình kể cả mình kiếm được tiền nhá kể cả
chưa bị thất nghiệp nhé Mình vẫn cảm
thấy trống rỗng lắm Mình cảm thấy là
mình đang sống sống hộ người khác các
bạn biết cái mấy cái từ đấy không ạ kiểu
thân thể này kiểu không còn thuộc về
mình nữa kiểu thế nghĩa là bạn đi làm
nhưng mà nó như
là
bạn bạn đang chỉ tồn tại thôi ý
đấy Không nói về những công việc mà bạn
làm theo đam mê nhá Có rất nhiều bạn mà
làm được theo đam mê Rất là ổn giống như
là mình Bây giờ mà may mà làm được đúng
đam mê Tôi chỉ nói những công việc phù
hợp thôi đúng không Bạn sẽ không bao giờ
bị chật vật lắm khi mà đi
phù hợp nữa đúng không Đấy Nói chung là
các bạn cũng phải tự khám phá bản thân
mình dần dần đúng không phải khám phá
phải phải thử phải thử mới biết được là
cái nào phù hợp nhiều người là
kiểu đừng có nhìn những người xung quanh
nữa Đừng có so sánh mình với tất cả
những người xung quanh nữa tự mình phải
phải cảm nhận được rõ dần là mình như
như nào như nào nữa đúng không Đừng đừng
so sánh mình với bạn bè Đừng so sánh
mình người xung quanh kệ đi so sánh mình
với chính mình ấy à Kiểu mình làm công
việc này mình mình đã phát triển được
bản thân hơn so với mấy tháng trước mấy
kiểu mấy tuần trước chưa Đấy mình mở
mang thêm cái gì không vân vân chứ kể cả
bạn làm công việc rất là ổn rồi chăng
nữa bạn vẫn hoàn toàn thể bị kiểu bị mất
việc bất cứ lúc nào nếu là sẽ sẽ một
ngày mà không thấy phù hợp nữa đúng
phù hợp đúng không đi làm chân tay thì
chắc chắn bạn cũng không thấy phù hợp
đúng không
rất nhiều nhưng mà Cái quan trọng
là cái thực ra để mà Nói tóm lại về Cái
ngành công ngệ tin ấy it ấy thì về cái
đầu tiên cái cốt lõi đó là khả năng tự
học phải rất là tốt đấy thứ hai đó là
kiểu
cũng chịu khó mề mò tìm hiểu đấy kh Tìm
Tò Nếu mà gặp được những người mà kiểu
cùng tìm cùng mình s v những tiền bối
đưa mình l khuyên mình có thêm bộng lực
mình biết được con đường kiểu phấn đấu
các th thứ thì càng tốt đúng không Chứ
còn
à Nói chung là cũng phải biết rõ ví dụ
ví dụ điển hình tôi thì thấy là tôi một
người lười một người thích kiểu làm cùng
người khác kiểu thế tôi sẽ phải đi Rủ
mọi người rủ ai đó đi ngồi làm việc cùng
đi ngồi cà phê cùng ngồi học cùng đấy
Kiểu thế tôi mới có động lực để tôi làm
vân vân hôi trước Thậm chí đi kiếm kiểu
đi kiếm người yêu kiếm bạn gái để mà
thêm động lực nghĩa là mình biết được là
mình kiểu con người Kiểu như thế thì
mình tìm khách đấy còn nếu mà khả năng
tự học tự kiểu ông thích một mình quen
nổ thì nó lại C tốt
tôi thấy những người hướng nội người ta
khả năng tựa học người ta cao ngườ ta
người ta ngồi một mình người ta học được
người ta không bị mất tập chung đấy nó
bị sáo Nhã đ mấy cũng phải vẫn rõ ra là
mình là con người như nào các thứ thứ
tính cách mọi thứ mình như thế nào Đừng
nghĩ việc bỏ cuộc vội mình phải thử nó
trong một khoảng thời gian các thứ thứ
đã thậm chí thử sang ngành khác một
khoảng thời gian đã chứ mình làm mới chỉ
có một hai tuần đ mình chứ không hiểu gì
mình nghĩ là nó khó thời gian đầu ai
chẳng cảm thấy khó đúng
không anh demo thử ci CD được không ạ
Không biết cụ thể ông muốn demo cái gì
nhưng mà chắc là tôi không chuyên ci
CD mình làm văn phòng nhiều đi bộ cũng
bị hụt hơi tôi lại nhớ cái câu chuyện
cười kiểu tôi đọc thôi trước đó là tôi
chạy thử code code không chạy tôi liền
chạy bộ rồi tôi nhận ra là code 07 thứ
duy nhất không chạy
tôi Ừ để tôi sẽ Thứ năm tôi sẽ lên văn
phòng mai tôi đi dậy mất rồi Thế năm tôi
Tôi quên mất đó là hôm nay vừa đọc được
bài của anh em trên văn phòng chia sẻ
kiểu ờ ngồi Nếu mà ngày nào cũng ngồi
máy tính làm việc văn phòng ấy thì việc
ông tập thể dục hàng ngày cũng không cải
thiện được mấy về cái sức khỏe của ông
ngĩa ít nhất là vẫn bị chĩ chẳng hạn đấy
Kiểu kiể thế đấy thế nên là tôi hôm nay
tôi bảo chiều nay tôi anh em sẽ ở ở văn
phòng Tôi có có cái bàn của sếp nhưng mà
X Sếp tôi đi công tác rồi thì đấy bàn
nâng hạ thì anh em bây giờ sẽ thay phiên
nhau nửa tiếng một lần kiểu anh em Có
laptop mà nửa tiếng một lần kiểu bê
laptop ra đứng ngồi codt ở trên cái bà
nâng hạ của sếp đấy chiều nay bận quá
quên mất để hôm sau tôi sẽ bắt đầu đặt
đặt lịch thể th thứ C chỉ cần đứng nửa
tiếng thôi đứng nửa tiếng ở mỏi chân rồi
đúng không ạ thay ca cho người khác đứng
kiểu thế Đỡ hơn tí đúng không ạ cũng gọi
là thỉnh thoảng mình nên không nên công
việc của mình là làm bằng đầu óc nên là
mình sẽ phải thoải mái được đầu óc nghĩa
là mình đôi khi không cần nhất thiệ phải
chăm chú nhìn mãi vào cái màn hình năm
xong nảy ra được cái suy nghĩ này ý
tưởng mình sẽ phải đổi mới thay đổi nó
tí đúng không mình đi lại xong mình suy
nghĩ thô đấy vận động một tí cũng được
không sao
đấy Thình thoảng giống như là sếp tôi
chẳng hạn thì vào qua r hoặc là tiktok
để ngắm mấy mấy bạn trăng trắng chọn
xinh
xinh rồi anh bảo đấy cách giải trí cũng
inter tìm ở đâu được anh ơi À đấy tôi
sẽ tôi tôi có báo với các bạn là trên
kênh discord ấy là tôi bây giờ sẽ lên
cái tôi tạo cái forum tuyển dụng ở đây
và hồi trước là tôi từng lên len để mà
xin rất nhiều rất rất nhiều cái CV à gd
cho các bạn Các bạn nhớ vụ đấy Hồi đấy
tôi có phải lại định làm cái trang web
môi giới việc làm ấy thì bây giờ thay vì
thế ch kiểu thôi cứ tạm bỏ qua cái trang
web đấy đi ạ thì bây giờ tôi sẽ lên lại
len một lần nữa lại mắt dày lại đi Kết
nối lại các bên kia đấy Có rất nhiều
người từng nhắn tin nhưng hồi đấy quá
bận để tổng hợp Vân Vân Vân Vân nó Chung
rất nhiều vấn đề đấy tôi sẽ tổng hợp
tổng hợp dần lại lên đây và có nhiều cái
hashtag này tôi sẽ đang kiểu nói chung
là đang nhiều đế nữa lên đây để cho mấy
ông kiểu lên đây tự filter nhá Đấy dụ Hồ
Chí Minh các thứ thứ như này ok không ạ
Đấy để mấy ông tự lên xem đương nhiên là
tôi nói ở đây nó cũng sẽ có một tí nhược
điểm là mấy ông thấy cơ hội mà có thì cơ
hội đến là tất cả thành ra mấy ông sẽ
cũng có tí kiểu cạnh tranh nhau đấy
nhưng
mà nhưng mà gọi như này tôi không nghĩ
cạnh tranh tỉ lệ nó cũng cao nhiều đến
thế Nói chung là cơ hội thì luôn có đúng
không Mình mình phải tự tạo dần dần dần
biết khi nào mới xem được live h Cái
live này Tâm sự Chắc không sao đâu em
học it 53 chỉ có kiến thức oop fql cơ
bản sắp tới đây cơ hội được giới thiệu
và công ty startup để thực tập Ừ ổn phết
công ty yêu cầu thời gian trên 20 gi một
tuần 20 gi một tuần là nếu mà 5 ngày là
4 tiếng một ngày Ok em Có nên vào không
hay dành thời gian để học thêm nhiều kỹ
năng lập trình
4 tiếng một ngày thì nó ít mà em em hoàn
toàn có thể vào thực tập và vẫn ở nhà
Thời gian còn lại vẫn thể học thêm được
mà thế là tốt đấy chứ có m cơ hội môi
trường để mà mình thực hành luôn công ty
n lý tưởng
đúng kiểu dạng là các bạn Nói chung là
đại khái là bây giờ mình bị kiểu nghĩ
nhiều ấy suy nghĩ rất nhiều nên là mình
à cái gì mà mình nghĩ trong một khoảng
thời gian mình không giải quyết được nó
ấy thì hãy đẩy vấn đề đấy cho người khác
người khác giải quyết hộ đấy Kiểu thế
nghĩa là đấy bạn thể đi hỏi người khác
đi hỏi những người các thứ thứ có thể hỗ
trợ được cho mình còn nếu mà vẫn chưa
được ấy phải gạt nó sang một bên bởi vì
nó là cái vấn đề mà bây giờ mình chưa
giải quyết được Mình chưa đủ trình độ để
giải quyết để trả đời đấy Để mình làm
những công việc khác những công việc
mình bây giờ có thể làm được chứ mình cứ
ngồi nghĩ mãi thì nó kiểu mình sẽ bị kẹt
mãi ở một chỗ chẳng làm được cái vấn đề
gì cả và mình sẽ gọi nh mình dậm chân
tại chỗ mình bị chôn chôn chân kiểu
giống kiểu cắt lún ý mình sẽ lún mãi ở
chỗ đấy đúng không Mình phải thoát nó
được ạ Không biết trả lời ông công nho
nhưng mà chính bản thân tôi tôi không
phải người lời học nhưng mà tôi là cũng
là người
tôi tính là tôi vẫn người rất là lười
nhá rất rất
lười tôi liệt kê cái tôi kể mấy ông rồi
tôi lệ kê một đống thứ là tôi sẽ học
này nhớ chưa học
này
ờ tôi đã Tôi đã đăng ký học một cái gì
đâu đấy tôi tôi cũng định lại hôm nay sẽ
đây hôm nay sẽ đăng ký lớp học luyện
thanh này đấy để tí Tôi đi tìm sau buổi
livestream này tôi sẽ đi tìm tôi sẽ hỏi
thêm vài chắc là tôi đang nh trong nhóm
kím các th thứ và hỏi thêm mọi người về
cái có khóa học luyện luyện thanh nó ổn
để mà mình sẽ đăng ký ít nhất là trước
mắt là cái đấy vì nó gọi là đăng ký mấy
cái kia thì nó học nó hơi bị nặng một tí
thì cái này Cứ nhẹ nhàng trước đã nhẹ
nhàng tình cảm trước đỡ phải động não
trước đã để mình có quen Dần và cái việc
là mình đi học phải lâu lắm mà không đi
học thật đấy Mình quen dần lại việc đi
học đã sau đó thì mình sẽ học dần dần dầ
các thứ khác sau đấy nghĩa là tôi Mục
tiêu của tôi đấy nghĩa là mình sẽ tự đặt
cho mình một cái mục tiêu nhẹ nhẹ nhàng
nhất để mình đạt được đã mình làm quen
dần với nó đạt được đã thì lúc đấy mình
mới kiểu nhảy sang cái học những cái khó
hơn đúng không Chứ bây giờ bảo tôi là
đùng phát vào học một cái thì khó luôn
thì đúng là ai cũng ngại thôi cái cái
ngại cái một trong những cái khó khăn
nhất là cái thời gian đầu mà thời gian
đầu làm quen mà đúng không ạ Đấy xong
rồi thờ xong rồi cái khó khăn tiếp theo
là cái khó khăn duy trì thói quen đấy
đúng không Thì ít nhất là mình sẽ phải
thường có khái niệm là 21 ngày à Nhưng
mà mình đâu học liên tục đâu th 21 ngày
nó hơi bị Hơi bị mô hồ thì thì tôi nghĩ
là bây giờ cái thứ hai mà để cho mình kỷ
luật hơn bản thân đó là mình sẽ không
được phép để mình nghỉ buổi nào ít nhất
là như thế để cho mình trước một khi
mình nghỉ rồi mình bị Tạo thói quen Mình
thích nghỉ đấy nên là mình sẽ phải tạo
dần những cái kỷ luật các thứ
thế ông em bảo kiếm một áp lực cũng đúng
kiếm người đi học cùng các thứ thứ nhưng
mà thực ra là nếu mà để để mà nói là tôi
cũng từng muốn kiểu có kiếm người đi học
cùng kiểu như thế nhưng mà nó sẽ bị
chính mình cũng bị phụ thuộc vào cái
người đấy nếu mà giả sử người đấy có vấn
đề gì đâ người hôm nay nghỉ chong mình
muốn nghỉ thừ hối trướng t từng kiểu hai
đứa lúc đầu đi học với nhau suốt rồi về
sau sẽ hết vào hàng nét
đấy đấy Nói chung là khó khó mà kiểu trừ
khi ông kiếm được một người kiểu ý chí
nghị lực cao hơn của ông thôi ông ông
đòi nghỉ nó đòi đi học cơ đấy phải như
thế Nhưng mà đừng để nó là thằng lái xe
nhá tôi trước đã từng thế tôi ẩn tôi với
thằng bạn hồi cấp hai thế kiểu hai đừa
tôi thì cứ bắt nó đi học học thêm đấy nó
qua đón tôi mà đi xe đạp qua đón tôi
xong rồi nó thì bảo muốn đi nét đấy S
rồi bảo anh em muà t tì đấy tôi thắng nó
vẫn muốn đi nét nó đèo đạp xe đi nét thế
thôi mình không muốn xuống mình cũng đi
cùng Nói chung là
thứ thứ Thế thì phụ thuộc rất nhiều cái
đừng có đừng có để bản thân mình bị phụ
thuộc như thế đúng không Mình nên tạo
những cái áp lực bở khác đấy có bạn gái
chẳng hạn khoe bạn gái là kiểu anh biết
tiếng Trung đấy Thế coi như là thành ra
là bạn phải học cấp tấp tiếng Trung vòng
ngày đang kể chuỗi lên n Tự nhiên đêm
qua Facebook đề xuất cái bạn với ng Yêu
Cũ 6 năm trước giờ suy cá không học được
đấy ông lại đang nhìn với góc độ kiểu bi
quan rồi Nếu giả sử Tôi nhìn thấy và
đúng thỉnh thoảng tôi có xem lại xem
người cũ bởi vì à Tôi có xem mấy cái
ngày ngày này năm xưa và thấy họ có
tương tác V bài đăng của mình thì tôi
vào xem các thứ xem thế nào đương nhiên
là tôi Xóa hết tin nhắn cũ nên không xem
được tôi cũng nhớ lại vân vân có người
lấy chồng rồi các thứ thì mình xem mình
tự nhiên mình nửa thì thấy đấy có người
lấy chồng rồi à là chồng thường là là
thành công một phần là thường lớn hơn
tuổi mình cá th vân vân đại khái thì
nhìn xong cũng tuổi thân một tí có kiểu
bây giờ mình đang nh đang một mình như
thế còn người ta
thì trông có vẻ hạnh phúc đấy Chắc họ h
hạnh phúc thật không phải trông đâu đấy
thì
à mình sẽ kiểu lấy đấy làm động lực thôi
mình sẽ phải phân đấu bởi vì họ tìm được
hạnh phúc thì mình cũng phải tìm được
hạnh phúc chứ bảo họ tìm được hạnh phúc
thì thôi mình nên Bất Hạnh à không đúng
không Mình sẽ nói chung là khi mà nhìn
vào một cái một cái gì đó tôi thường
ngay cố biến nó lạc quan theo kiểu như
thế chứ mình ngồi dặn vặt bản thân mãi
cũng có làm được cái gì đâu đúng
không Họ đang sinh viên năm 4 à Tôi đang
ví dụ
Vân Vân Như nào các thứ thứ thì ông chỉ
có kiểu gọi
là bây giờ Tôi tin là có thể người yêu
cũ cũng thấy nick của ông Xong bây giờ
ông phải thể hiện là ông cũng đang ra vẻ
ít nhất là ông phải ra vẻ hạnh phúc
thành công cho họ cũng cảm thấy kiểu
kiểu tiếc chứ Bây giờ ông tiếc họ họ
không tiếc ông thì ông phải đúng Xem ông
phải xem lại bản thân thật nghĩa là có
thì tôi Hồi trước có cái câu nghe câu đó
là kiểu nó hơi phũ một tí nhưng mài thế
thì nó chia tay mày là đúng đấy Kiểu
kiểu thế rõ ràng kiểu mấy năm sau mày
vẫn thế họ mà nó Phả tốt hơn đúng không
đấy Kiểu không thể thế được đúng không
sẽ phải là kiểu Ui dá mà kiểu không Thế
ạ Không phải dùng từ Giá mà Thì kiểu Giá
mà mình không chia tay anh đấy nhưng mà
nói chung là ý là cũng gọi
như tôi thấy cái đấy cũng có thể B Tính
làm làm động lực Được
đấy ông n thiếu động lực mà Đúng không
ông nhìn vào đấy lấy thấy là động lực
thôi cò gì
đây mế không không phải nghĩ ui đỉnh
vậy hi vọng bạn này chưa bị à thôi Chắc
không sao đâu tại tôi thường hay trêu
các bạn kế toán mà
Ờ công ty anh có tuyển không Anh ờ câu
trả lời trước Tết là có còn bây giờ thì
không Bởi vì Trước Tết tôi còn đang tự
tin tôi khoe mấy ông là kiểu công ty tôi
mang tiếng là cái Thời buổi kinh tế khó
khăn
này mà vẫn có thể dám tuyển thêm mà
không đuổi thêm không đuổi không cắt
giảm nhân sự đó công ty đang phát triển
rất là thành công đúng không ạ nhưng còn
bây giờ
thì bây giờ không phải là không phát
triển thành công hay là bây giờ đang có
như nào đấy mà chỉ đang nói là bây giờ
đang lại khá là ổn định nên là Nên là
các anh đấy Đang kiểu cảm thấy khá là
kiểu gọi là nó thực ra là tôi đang ngồi
hôm mà tôi ngồi nói chuyện với sếp ấy
thì sếp cũng có chia sẻ đúng kiểu sếp
Tuy sếp là dân công nghệ cto nhá Nhưng
mà Sếp tôi lại rất là giỏi tính toán
chuyên toán mà nên là có đầu óc kiểu về
kinh doanh các thứ các thứ thì nói luôn
nó là B về bài toán kinh doanh thôi bắ
sếp mà đấy
thì khi mà thuê một người về thì cái cái
đương nhiên là cái chi phí bỏ ra thuê
một người đấy thì thì nó phải đổi lại
được rất nhiều giá trị như thế nào phải
gấp hai gấp ba và gấp nhiều lên thì mới
được chứ không phải là là thích thì cứ
tuyển thêm đúng không ạ Đấy khi mà những
anh em hiện tại vẫn đang làm được việc
rất tốt cũng việc cũng không bị nặng quá
Không quá quá nhiều deadline anh em vẫn
hoàn hành được ấy vẫn kịp Tiếm độ ấy chứ
không phải bị gồng quá Và nếu mà giả sử
mà
có có cần thì thực ra là tăng lương cho
anh em hiện tại một chút nó còn có lợi
hơn so với việc là tuyển hơn thêm một
người mới nữa Bởi vì nếu mà càng đông ấy
Sếp tôi có quan điểm là nếu mà càng đông
th ra mọi người sẽ ỷ lại thôi kiểu ô tao
không làm thì có thằng khác làm kiểu thế
Bây giờ việc ít người nhưng mà nó chất
lượng theo kiểu là anh em ai cũng đảm
nhận được một vị trí nào đó một cái tầm
quan trọng nà đó ai thấy mình có sức ảnh
hưởng thì họ sẽ có thêm tinh thần kiểu
muốn làm và tự giác hơn khi có vấn đề
thì nghĩ là mình có một phần trách nhiệm
trong đấy để mà mình làm chứ chứ bây giờ
bị đông của hó nó sẽ bị loãng đúng không
m không hiểu Nói chung là các sếp mà Thì
đương nhiên các sếp nói thì lúc nào cũng
có thể hay nhưng mà như tầm nhìn tôi
thấy là nó cũng hợp lý và đấy nghe cũng
hay mà mà tuyển thêm một ông mới cũng
cứng cứng đi phải 20 25 đúng không chia
đều cho anh em cái số tiền đấy kiểu ví
dụ bây giờ đang có năm anh em có dự án
thì chỉ cho anh em lên hẳn 5 triệu nó
hơi quá Nhưng mà kiểu cho anh em lên 2 3
triệu cái Ôi mấy anh em vừa vui vừa làm
hứng khởi hơn các thứ thứ nó đoàn kết
hơn đúng không Bây giờ thêm hẳn một ông
mới về mà ông ấy không hợp Văn Hóa thì
có khi mất đoàn kết hơn đúng không Mình
có hiểu không Nói chung
là cái
việc hiện tại nói chung là để Tóng tắt
lại trả lời cái câu hỏi kia th công ty
tôi đang tạm ngưng là
không
không không tuyển thêm Bởi vì bây giờ
chưa chưa bị quả Tải công việc Nhưng mà
khi mà bị qu tài thì chắc chắn sẽ tuyển
thêm tính ra thì công ty tôi đang chỉ có
nă anh em đ cái dự án mới thì đang chỉ 5
anh
chán không hợp thì làm sao anh em thấy
trên đời không có việc gì làm em hứng
thú hết có nghĩa là ai sẽ khoảng thời
gian đấy Ông cứ thử giống như Ông em tôi
ông em đang ngồi bình luận kìa ông Em ấy
thử một khoảng thời gian kiểu gần nửa
năm hay một năm gì đấy em ấy đi làm bồi
bàn hay là làm công việc khác đ xem mấy
kiểu nhớ ấ Uầy Nếu mà chuẩn mà ông thấy
phù hợp với ngành này ấ thì chỉ cần một
tháng ông không ngồi cốt nữa thôi ông sẽ
nhớ C thử thử kiểu kiểu bị bị nó hơi bị
nghiện một tí đấy kểu
thế Còn nếu không thì có khi ông không
phù hợp thật không có giờ làm nhữ công
việc khác đi có sao
đâu chứ Nếu mà bây giờ ông cứ
kiểu kiểu ông ông ông cứ ông cứ ép bản
thân mình làm cái gì đó đấy chắc chắn về
sau ông sẽ vẫn có cái suy nghĩ nảy nảy
ra trong đầu như này mình không phù hợp
với công việc này thì sao đấy V ông có
thể làm khác đi Ít ra nó còn đỡ tội lỗi
hơn so việc là ông ông hẹn hò hay ông
thậm chí hôn nhân các thứ ông nhìn núi
này trông núi nọ thì ông mới làm cái gì
đó Tội Lỗi cái gì Vi PH phạm đạo đức một
cái gì đó kiểu không nên không nên thử
cho dù chỉ một lần đấy còn còn công việc
thì tính ra là ông thích thì ông bỏ
ngang nó để ông làm một cái khác vẫn
không ai kiến gì cả Chẳng sao cả đúng
không Cái này có thể thử được đấy cứ thử
chán chê Đi sau ông quay lại công việc
hiện tại thì nó khác đúng
không trước anh tự học như nào vậy
ạ Tôi học thì ở trên trường sau đó thì
tôi tự nghĩ ra rất nhiều ý tưởng thì tôi
ngồi làm thêm và tôi chia sẻ trọng cộng
đồng rồi Nhiều anh em kiểu góp ý nhiều
anh em sử dụng tôi lại cảm thấy là mình
làm được Kiểu những cái thứ đem lại giá
trị mình vui mình thích đấy Kiểu thế có
người dùng được đấy nên là mình lại
thích m mò tìm hiểu thêm đấy Xong rồi
lúc đi làm thì tôi ham kiểu ham hỏi cũng
gặp được rất nhiu nhều kiểu người tiền
bối người đi trước người ta hỗ trợ cho
cái sự kiểu ham hỏi của tôi hỏi nhiều
cực đến bây giờ tôi vẫn hỏi tôi hỏi
Nhiều kinh khủng luôn anh xếp ở bên cạnh
anh ấy cũng rất nhiều lúc cứ chế có ngay
ngay bây giờ nhé tôi đi làm tôi hỏi liên
tục luôn tôi chỉ có làm với hỏi thôi
Không nói nói chuyện riêng thỉnh thoảng
có
Nói chung là tôi cảm thấy là tôi cũng
thích nhận năng lượng người khác nữa nên
tôi sẽ thích làm việc những người anh em
xung quanh rồi xong rồi trao đổi các thứ
thứ
môi trường và công kiểu những người như
thế thì ông đấy là trong trường hợp mà
ông kiểu tính cách là nào giống tôi tôi
hứng ngoại mà còn không thì ông phải ông
phải phải tự khám phá bản thân mình xem
mình hợp với cái gì
đâu th bảo anh biết tiếng Trung chứ bảo
anh giỏi tiếng Trung đâu biết thôi mà em
biết tiếng An anh biết tiếng em nữa này
chẳng hạn đấy thế là được còn học thì
học cách hiểu của cấu lệnh và kiến trục
cách vận dụng ok rồi còn cụ thể chi tiết
không cần phải nhớ quá đúng sao có gì
bây giờ ai hỗ trợ tận răng rồi mà các
bạn chỉ cần gõ kiểu mình cần làm gì làm
gì nó sẽ gợi ý hỗ trợ từng bước từng
bước mình là mình hiểu về quy trình các
thứ được
mà
Uầy làm cho bà Lan từ phải xem vụi bà
Lan xong ơ
Uy Nhưng mà bên này to
mà không sao đấy Đấy bây giờ cuộc đời đã
cho bạn một cơ hội nữa để mà làm lại
cuộc
đời nên là bạn bạn đừng bỏ lỡ cơ hội này
nhá
anh ơi em sắp ra trường rồi Em học pp
larel mà thấy ít tiền ít
quá Em đừng có theo việc là công ty
tuyển nhiều các th thứ tuyển nhiều thì
cũng nhiều người cạnh tranh Thôi em cứ
học ổn đã rồi em Em phải làm chắc cái
một cái đã xong rồi
em khi mà em phỏng vấn ấy thậm chí em
phỏng vấn vào công cái bên ngôn ngữ khác
cũng được được người ta hỏi chủ yếu
người ta hỏi tư duy thôi chứ Kiểu gì
người ta chẳng dạy lại cho các em
thì quan trọng là em làm được ra một cái
sản phẩm nào đó để khoe đã đấy s Kiểu gì
người ta cũng sẽ phải đào tạo lại và và
người ta sẽ vứt tài liệu cho em để em tự
học lại thôi cho đừng quan trọng về ngôn
ngữ em ạ ngôn ngữ nào như nhau
việc nó chỉ vậy chứ nhiều việc hơn là
phải tuyến thêm ngay một phần cũng đúng
bởi vì bây giờ Bây giờ là việc thực ra
để mà nói là không ít việc đâu nhưng mà
ít nhất ở trong khoảng thời gian này bởi
vì giữa năm mà giữa năm thì nó không bị
quá tải các thứ chứ tầm đầu năm và cuối
năm sẽ khá là quá tải lúc đấy sẽ phải
cân nhắc thêm
thật em đi làm bồi bàn nhưng vẫn cốt nhé
Đấy nghĩa
chỉ là
ông ông đấy ông em thấy mình phù hợp với
ngành này bởi vì kiểu làm công việc khác
vẫn nhớ đến ngành này đúng không thử đi
B vác đi ông sang chập ti lý luôn Tôi
nhớ năm nhất tôi quá năm nhất tôi vừa
làm bồi bàn kiểu đi bê bề thùng đá thằng
bia xong rồi làm ở siêu thị cũng đi bê
đồ sắp xếp đồ ấy Kiểu mình suýt làm nhân
viên của tháng được cho đến khi mình
mình kiểu sức khỏe không cho phép thứ
thứ nế Hồi đấy tôi cũng cây
thật tôi tự học lập trình và Trước đó
tôi không có kiến thức gì lập trình hết
tôi bắt đầu lúc 27 tuổi đây già trong
ngành
mình cũng gi
chị
ờ trong kênh trong kênh của em có rất
nhiều nhiều Em thích các Phú
trị
đấy có phú trị kìa Mấy ông tranh thủ làm
quen
đấy Gần đây tôi phát âm t đúng từ back
end rồi hồi trước bị cứ quen gọi B à Em
định học lập trình C C cộng xong kiến
trúc dữ liệu g dữ liệu gì gì đó
JavaScript
và SQL fen backen được em V học theo lội
trình đấy thôi nghe ổn đấy
mới khó
đúng Hồi trước tôi cũng không biết hỏi
như nào nên là Hồi đấy tôi cũng chia sẻ
mấy ông về cách hỏi rồi đó là thứ nhất
là mấy ông sẽ phải nói là mấy ông muốn
làm muốn làm kiểu nó Nó kiểu CP bước à
Muốn làm ra một cái tính năng gì gì đó
đúng không Nó sẽ hiển thị ra như vân vân
vân ví dụ giả sử em muốn làm cái kiểu
bấm vàoo cái nút này nó hiển đị ở cửa sổ
Hiển đị những thông tin như này này x
thử vẽ ra được cái gì gì đó tốt đấy x em
không hể biết được từ khóa và cách làm
cái đấy như nào không biết được ngôn ngữ
làm cái nào vân vân chẳng hạn đấy Xong
rồi nói chung cái thứ nhất ông sẽ phải
nói được là ý tự là mình muốn làm gì đã
thứ hai
là cái thứ hai nó là
kiểu đấy thì em cũng phải nói qua là
mình đã tìm tỏi các thứ thứ mình đã thử
những cái gì đấy ý tưởng là gì Vân vân
đấy Nói chung là
ờ cái về kỹ năng hỏi phải biết phải cói
có kỹ năng hỏi nữa thậm chí là thường
Đừng có bảo người ta cầm tay chỉ lối
mình còn nhiều quá bảo người ta gợi ý
mình tử khóa để mình tự tra mình tự mò
đúng rồi Đợt dịch đợt mà thay đổi khá
nhiều nhân sự và vân vân kiểu nó cũng
làm thay đổi rất nhiều
Thời
là bạn lập gia đình khoảng thời gian này
cũng được sau đó thì nhận job freeland
cũng
ba này tester cũng được
tester mà biết SQL lợi thế tốt phết đấy
nên bạn có thể xem khoa học dạy SQL của
tôi đặt câu hỏi ở đâu thế Mọi người ơi
tôi có gim cái link bit chd kìa để mà
các bạn bấm và Chắc để tôi ghi
lại ghi này sợ mọi người không hiểu được
đây link ĐT câu hỏi à đặt câu
hỏi ở đ đây
nha
đạch trong này nó không trong này không
tham khảo với hay kéo em theo cũng được
đấy rõ ràng đấy có phú trị cái mọi thứ
XM h
hn cách hỏi thế nào để không bị chửi
phải biết cách hỏi cũng đúng Nói chung
là đừng có làm phiền người ta quá tôi
hỏi nhiều lắm nhưng nhiều lúc cũng th
nhiều lúc cũng cảm thấy mình phiền thật
vì rõ ràng tôi bảo rồi đừng có nghĩ rằng
là sếp của mình hay leader của mình là
là phải chịu trách nhiệm V việc mình à
là là chịu trách nhiệm việc mình có thể
hỏi thoải mái hay giúp mình mọi thứ họ
cũng có công việc của họ trách nhiệm của
họ không phải là giúp mỗi mình mình Vân
Vân đúng không nên là mình cũng phải tỏ
thiện chí một tí giống như là kiểu thỉnh
thoảng tôi cũng không phải nịnh xếp
nhưng mà sẽ phải biết cách nói sếp thậm
chí là kiểu đấy Cảm ơn sếp Vân Vân Vân
Vân thể hiện mình là
kiểu mình rất trân trọng mọi thứ mà họ
đã có thể hỗ trợ cho mình nói chung là
về cái bài toán gọi là biết điều một tí
kỹ năng mềm nó phải ổn một tí đấy thì
thì thì ai cũng sẵn sàng có thể hỗ trợ
được bạn thôi đúng không Mà Lã cả là khi
mà họ hỗ trợ mình xong mình làm được tốt
công việc thì thực ra họ cũng sẽ và
thỉnh thoảng mình hỗ trợ lại đ cho chính
họ nữa tôi nói chuyện với sếp các thứ
các thứ tôi vẫn kiểu nói chung là làm
cho sếp cảm thấy là ừ thằng này kiểu
dạng là à mình mình kiểu tạo điều kiện
cho nó nó thì nó hoàn toàn kiểu
ờ tốt được cho công ty tốt được cho công
việc đấy hoàn toàn được mà đúng
không
SQL can tốt anola cân tốt Angola và nots
Á làm tester Vẫn ok nhỉ Ừ đúng các bạn
biết một tí lập trình xong rồi SQL nữa u
ngôn ngữ lập
trình Thực ra làm như thế làm thêm cả da
hoặc ba đều được Kiểu thế xịn mà nói
chung là Làm lập trình viên thì khó mà
làm lập trình viên viên mãi được về sau
vẫn nhảy sang được mấy cái mạng kia thôi
mà lên mảng kia lên hẳn Làm lí luôn ý
đấy bởi vì là mình biết về chuyên môn
biết về nghiệp vụ các thứ tự mình làm từ
đầu đến cuối được một
thứ Biết đâu lại thấy codde có bấc nhảy
vào phích hộ luôn
ứng viên chư anh Anh chưa biết vụ đấy
nhưng mà anh nghĩ là vụ đấy nó cũng
chẳng hiếm lắm giống kiểu Google nó
tuyển có khi cũng gắt mà anh đã làm dự
án tốt nghiệp hướng em làm giống web udi
Liệu có ổn không
cáo trước toàn hỏi câu web em có gì tốt
hơn so với web người ta Hoang Mang qu
Anh thức ra là chẳng cần phải nói tốt
hơn đâu gọi là phải nói là web người ta
có cái gì em có cái đấy đấy web người ta
thấy mạnh là gì Em có cái đấy Đấy thế là
đủ quá xịn rồi thì rõ ràng là mình sinh
viên thôi mà mình kể cả mình đi làm ở
ngoài kể cả đi làm ở ngoài luôn Ví dụ
Giả sử công ty tôi luôn này công ty tôi
là làm trang web kiểu trang thương mại
điện tử thì đương nhiên nó sẽ có rất
nhiều trang thương mại điện tử có sẵn
rồi đúng không ạ Mình không phải thằng
đầu tiên có ý tưởng đấy đúng không cái
đầu tiên Bọn tôi phấn đấu đó là tôi bằng
bọn bọn hiện tại bọn hiện tại có cái gì
bọn tôi có hết cái đấy đấy Cái đầu tiên
là như thế đã đấy Sau đó thì về sau là
mình sẽ phát triển nên cái gì đó riêng
riêng của mình nhưng nói thẳng luôn là
hôm
trước hôm trước lúc mà có trao đổi riêng
với sếp s Anh Bình anh leader Của Tôi có
tra đổi riêng với anh cto của sếp à Anh
C đấy Thì hỏi luôn là mình có lợi thế
cạnh tranh gì đấy Nói thẳng luôn là à
Không có cái gì đó công nghệ quá công
nghệ lõi không có để mà nó quá xịn để mà
Thằng thằng đối thủ khác không thể copy
được không Không có công nghệ lõi đấy th
nhất là mình chỉ đang thứ nhất là mình
có tệp khách hàng cũng tiềm năng nên là
nhiều anh em khách Hàn tiềm năng vẫn
đang ủng hộ vẫn đang dùng bên mình đấy
thứ hai đó là kiểu Ừ thì mình mới non
trẻ hơn nên mình hoàn toàn thể thay đổi
được những cái ông lớn kia thì nó sẽ bị
nhược điểm đó là những ông lớn thì muốn
thay đổi một cái gì đó rất là khó còn
mình thì kiểu mình vẫn còn còn bé mình
vẫn đang chiều khách hàng Khách hàng đòi
thêm tính năng gì mình vẫn hỗ trợ cung
cấp thêm được đấy vân vân đấy chứ Còn
chứ còn để mà cạnh tranh được mấy ông
lớn đấy Nói thẳng luôn rất là khó vì vì
bọn nó kiểu giữa cái đội ngũ nó trăm
trăm người nghìn người chẳng hạn đúng
không Mình mình còn đang dùng những cái
thư viện gọi là thư viện có sẵn trên
mạng còn nó thì một là nó mua hẳn cái bả
mới phí hai nó tự khẳn làm ra những cái
thư viện đấy luôn hôm trước tôi xem
thằng ấy gọi đỉnh vãi trưởng nó còn bình
thường ví dụ ví dụ mình còn đang phải
dùng bú ch nó còn tự Build một cái
Framework CS rồi có hẳn một cái trang
tài liệu cho cái đấy ạ thằng sp spotify
ấ à đâu không phải tôi toàn nhầm
spotify shop
đấy
trang chia sẻ cái Framework CS của nó
trang tài liệu CS định
mãi nghĩa là không
kiểu nó t tâm các thứ thứ ghê thế rồi
đấy mình mình quay lại nhìn cái trang
tài liệu của mình C tạp
nham rất khó đúng không nhưng mà bọn tôi
không ngại cạnh tranh với nó mình đã
cạnh tranh mình phải cạnh tranh mấy
thằng top đầu chứ đúng không Cạnh tranh
mấy đứa ao làng làm gì
đấy gọi nhở nó đang nó đang kiếm được Cứ
cho là 100 à không phải 100 nó đang kiếm
100 thì mình mình Thực ra bây giờ mình
mục tiêu mình chỉ kiếm 1 cho đến 10 pH
của nó 10 ph so với nó ấy đã cũng quá
quá bé bờ quá ổn rồi vì đội ngũ của mình
chắc chắn là thấp hơn nó rất là nhiều
vân vân tự nhên là nó hơi sâu xa quá
thông cả rồi quay lại tiếp nhỉ Đang nói
dợ cái gì
nhỉ nói chung là tự tin lên An em ạ
Không
đúng không
rect là như
thì vui mà lương bổng Chán quá
Ông đúng kiểu dạng là nếu mà làm nhiều
nơi thì đãy ngộ một thứ nó thể không
thoải mái như mình muốn thật thì thế
thực ra mình vẫn có cách để mà điu lương
ha mọi thứ hoặc chuyển công ty Nói chung
là phải dựa Xem chính cái sản phẩm các
thứ vân vân đã và hiện tại ông đặt nặng
gánh nặng về cái
lương hay không đã vì rõ ràng Nếu mà
trong khoảng th gian này ông vẫn học
được ông vẫn làm được và sản phẩm rất là
tốt có tiềm năng thì thự ra là về sau
Kiểu gì nó sẽ bùng nổ nó sẽ kiểu mình sẽ
được nhiều cái hơn thôi còn nếu gi sử
sản phẩm nó cứ đều đều đều như thế ông
học chỉ thế thi thì mình cũng phải cân
nhắc chuyển dần chứ không thì về sau
mình sang công ty khác nó khó đúng
không nghe đồn con ai divin mới ra tự có
tự fb các thứ tester sẽ hẹo
trước Thực ra thì tôi đúng là tôi Công
nhận rất là bất ngờ khi mà hồi trước thì
thường ha Tự tin là lập trình viên mình
là một cái nghề khó thay thế với ai
Nhưng bây giờ ai nó còn đang đánh thẳng
vào cái đấy vì ai nó nói thẳng luôn là
ai học code của mình nhiều quá nghĩa là
rõ ràng nó học những cái mảng
khác Nó có thể học những mảng khác trước
mà nó đánh bại cái khác trước nhưng
không Tôi thấy là ai bây giờ rất nhiều a
mới nó cứ kiểu kiểu gì nó cũng học toán
này xong HC toán vân vân vân học cả code
các thứ thứ bởi vì cái đấy là cái thứ mà
chia sẻ được rất nhiều và nó học từ
chính cái nguồn đấy trước thậm chí là
những câu hỏi tự nhiên có khi nó không
trả lời sõi bằng cái việc mấy cái kia về
mấy cái kia tính ra nó được viết kiểu nó
nguồn nó rộng ấy à nguồn nó kiểu cũng
tương đối chứ mấy cái kia thì nguồn nó
rộng quá thì thằng ai nó học không hết
đấy
n Tôi cảm thấy là là đúng Anh em mình
cũng cũng sẽ bị ảnh hưởng rất nhiều
nhưng mà ảnh hưởng Đây là ảnh hưởng cho
nó vừa là nó cũng khó mà có thể thay thế
được mình hoàn toàn lắm tởi vì công việc
này mà biến mất thì công việc khác nó
lại sinh ra
thôi và đặc biệt là quan trọng là mình
có tư duy thì kiểu gì mình sẽ sống được
tin là như thế không bị thay thế hoàn
toàn đâu
ngành Không thực ra là công ty tôi không
tuyển theo dựa theo bằng cấp í nh là thế
vì nó công ty setup thì không yêu cầu
Khắt cao Khắt cao mấy cái đấy
h học kế
toán Tôi vẫn nhớ có một người cũng bình
luận thêm một câu nữa đó
là ai không để thay thế được cô giáo trẻ
Mấm non vì A không thể rửa rửa mông cho
trẻ con c thư thừ đọc cái đấy ốn
không đi tù được đúng
con ai nó tự feedb cho chính nó không
con ai mới gần đây thì có
ấy Ừ tôi cũng chưa biết soc là gì luôn
đang m tên cho con Web 6 năm trước cách
hai đọc code khoai thật bởi đôi khi mấy
ông làm những cái dự án kiểu Legacy kiểu
mấy cái cũ Thế thấy mất kiên nhẫn vãi
trưởng đặc biệt là nếu nó là product nữa
u mang tiếng là nhiều người code product
như là code rất là tệ nhá nói chung là
trong ngành này vào ngành mới biết được
muôn chúng nó đau đầu người thì tìm mãi
mới kiếm được việc người thì đang ở
trong môi trường rồi nên thể rất là tệ
đấy Nói chung là rất nhiều rất nhiều các
thứ thứ không không thể nói công việc
nào là công việc như mơ được đâ th dù kể
cả it là vua của mọi nghề nữa đúng
không Anh nghĩ sao về uiux design như cơ
hộ việc làm các thứ ý
ờ Nếu mà em chỉ làm mũi uiux Design thì
theo anh cơ hội rất thấp bởi vì C không
cần em phải làm bên full stack à à à đâu
fance nhưng mà anh nghĩa là em
A Nói chung là nó hơi bị giới hạn ấy anh
cảm thấy thế ví dụ ngay ở thời điểm công
ty hiện tại của anh không có một ông
design chính thức cần vấn đề gì thỉnh
thoảng sẽ thuê ông kiểu pam ông cộng ta
viên là làm design hộ thường là chính
ông fen ông sẽ kiêm luôn việc đấy đấy
đấy anh cũng quen rất nhiều kiểu như thế
nên là thậm chí là có những người anh
biết làm u rất là tốt cuối cùng cũng
phải bỏ hoặc là chuyển qua phải kiêm
thêm những cái công việc khác
đọc lại không hiểu hồi xưa code sao chạy
được tôi Tôi luôn nhớ được logic Tại sao
tôi COD cái đoạn đấy tôi tôi nhớ tôi có
thể đọc và hiểu được code cũ của tôi tại
sao tôi lại làm thế giải thích được vì
nói chung là mình nếu mà tư duy mình
trưa sau như một the kiểu là không phải
là mình vẫn trình độ đấy nhá như không
thế nhưng mà nói chung là đại khái
thì đấy Đấy gần như là mình hiểu được
mình mà trí nhớ mình cũng phải tốt phải
định đấy tôi nhớ được đấy tôi giải thích
được hôm nay tôi Vừ giải thích cho sếp
tôi mà cái code 3 năm trước đúng nghĩa 3
năm trước luôn
2021 tôi vẫn ngồi giải thích lý do tại
sao tôi code của đoạn
đấy là code Tôi khẳng định luôn code đầu
tiên của tôi Tôi cũng ngồi giải thích
được tôi hôm trước tôi bảo mấy ông ấy
ngồi code trang trên g của tôi có mấy
code kiểu 7 năm trước 6 năm trước có tôi
vẫn đương nhiên mấy cái đoạn code đấy nó
vẫn tương đối ngắn nên thành ra nó vẫn
dễ hiểu nhưng mà ý tôi là tôi vẫn nhớ
quên đấy quên
được nhưng không gọi được Ok anh cứ chữa
tề m đây
nhá
ông ông nào cần hỏi thì bấm vàoo link để
hỏi nhá đ tôi trả lời dần
nhá mô tả nghiệp vụ quản lý kho trong
quá trình quản lý kho Phê quá trình
nghiệp vụ tạo đơn yêu cầu các mặt hàng
trong kho ghi chết quy trình nhập hàng
quản lý và kiểm soát số lượng hàng hóa
trong kho quy trình xất và sử dụng hàng
và lập và Cáo nó cứ bị Trung Trung
nhở để quản lý lô hàng hạ sử dụng và
kiểm soát quản lý sẽ nhập cập nhật và
shit lưu lại số lượng hàng hóa hiện
này nhập cập nhật số lượng Vân Vân
này lưu gại loại hàng này nhà cung cấp
Bin l cũng được Nói chung là có thêm bên
la đấy lưu lại bên la được còn tốt ký
nhận các thứ thứ thứ không quan tâm cái
này là không Bin Chắc là giấy tơ văn bản
chứ làm sao mình Mình lưu lại chữ ký mọi
thứ mình ký on chắc tạm bỏ qua cái chữ
ký điện
nh trên máy Phan đánh số lượng mới cái
này cũng Dy nhiên nó sẽ kiểu double
check là kiểu Mình sẽ lưu lại thông tin
trong sổ nữa phải mỗi
máy
quy trình xất và sử dụng đã bán số lượng
tôi
h Nói chung là cái này phải quản lý kho
chứ không phải quản lý quán cà phê
cập về kho chứ không liên quan việc là
đề
xất cái này tôi không biết được là cái
này là áp dụng cho thực tế
không áp dụng cho cho kiểu dạng là gọi
như là ý ý ý ý tôi là kiểu Cái này chỉ
là bài toán ở kiểu dạng giải quyết bài
toán ở trên trên trường kiểu đề bài như
thế hay là thực tế là đang làm rồi Nếu
mà đang làm rồi thì nó sẽ cần phải có
rất nhiều tính năng chi tiết các thứ còn
nếu
mà đúng rồi nó chỉ bài tập các thứ thứ
có mấy cái kiểu như này này thì mình sẽ
chỉ làm mức tương đối Ức lượng gọi là
đầy đủ các tính năng cơ bản Hy dùng từ
cơ bản trước đã sau đó thì mình sẽ muốn
chi tiết vào cái nào chi tiết cụ thể một
vài cái tính năng kiểu dạng là nâng cao
một tí chứ còn nếu mà bài toán thực tế
mình sẽ phải thiết kế một cách chặt chẽ
hơn và tính năng nào cũng phải kiểu nâng
cao một tí vì rõ ràng là mấy cái liên
quan đến quản lý gì đó thì mình phải rất
là tiện cho người dùng về thường nó có
sẵn dữ liệu vân vân rồi
sẽ bao gồm việc có sẵn Google sheet rồi
chẳng hạn mình nhập vào này thậm chí là
có cả quét mã các thứ thứ quét bên l các
thứ các thứ để mà để ra được chứ không
phải là nhập tay thủ công hết thì nó tốn
thời gian đúng không
ạ
Ừ Ok Để tôi xem qua về cơ sở liệu bạn
nhá có mã thường là tôi bảo là các bạn
hạn chế để lúc thì tiếng Anh kiểu ID
kiểu này lúc tiếng Việt này nếu mà để
tiếng Anh hết thì tốt à nhầm để hết một
ngôn ngữ Nếu mà giả sử không biết tiếng
Anh thì để hết tiếng Việt đúng không
thường là cột mã thôi không phải mã hàng
hóa như này không nên lặp lại tên bảng
này mã loại hàng loại hàng loại hàng ở
đây đúng không tên tên này Đấy đơn vị
tính
Ok mình sẽ vẽ sơ đồi một khể trước D
hình dung
đi quản lý đúng không
Thế quản lý đấy nó sẽ cần làm tính năng
gì à Không phải số đồ thể đây là UK chứ
hã số đồ UK là kiểu mình làm được những
tính năng gì Vân vân vân có sơ đồ rồi à
À đây đây đây T sao lưu lại dạng
này à đây Ok em cũng vẽ rồi xem thử link
dài
thế chắc không phải link virus gì
hiểu của tôi đã như mà xem qua trước bạn
lại vẽ như nào
nhỉ Không biết đủ link hay
không sợ link này thường ha nó có một
cái đội dài nhất định thôi à Đây là link
ảnh này ồ và sao
sao đây là s
đồ đây
là đâu Đây đâu phải S đồ thực thể đâu à
đây thực thể bên này
OK thực thể này nhìn nó vẫn khó hiểu ạ
Anh đang định vẽ UK
thể thì làm gì có ch chi tiết các thứ
thứ này n bị nhầm rồi Cái này không phải
thực thể đâu Nó là mối quan hệ bảng các
thứ
phải nhớ lại cái thực
thể thực thể thì nó nó nói lên tất cả
thôi Nó là cái gì nó là thực tế kiểu
hiện hữu ấy thì nó là thực thể làm gì có
thực thể nà chi tiết hóa đơn đúng
không nó chỉ có thực thể hóa đơn thôi nó
sẽ nó sẽ từ hóa đơn với sản phẩm nó mối
quan hệ như nào tạo ra một cái bảng
trung gian các thứ thứ Nếu mà nn nó sẽ
tạo bảng trung gian các thứ đấy Nói
chung là đại khái Thì bây giờ mình dựa
vào cái này dựa cái này quản lý nó sẽ
tương tác với cái kho Nếu giả sử có một
kho thi nhá Ok Giả sử có một kho thôi
thì nó cũng dễ nó sẽ là quản lý tương
tác với với hàng hóa này đúng
này hàng hóa sản phẩm các thứ này
Đấy xong rồi
Ơ ơ tôi l
[âm nhạc]
ấn Ctrl
z à ctrl V hàng
hóa rồi Tiếp theo
Ờ có loại hàng đúng không loại
hàng tiếp theo nữa
là
Ừm shit các thứ B qua đi số lượng các
thứ các
thứ đây Nếu thế thì vẽ theo kiểu entity
nhá ch dễ
quan đến số lượng này Đấy Và đây
này mấy cái cột khác không quan trọng
thì cứ mình cứ tạm ẩn đi
nào anh trả lời dần dần
sao
dùng start uml mới chuẩn À chưa biết cái
này cái cái đấy cái gì st ull Ồ chố xị
mất
này Bin l cái gì gì đó Cứ cho là có một
cái Bin đi Ok có một cái bin
sẽ kiểu bôi đen hết tất cả ấy bine này
nĩa mình làm việc với hàng hóa các thứ
nó sẽ ra cái Bin
ok
ừ đây theo kiểu UK nhá theo kiểu UK
trước nhá chứ còn còn về sau kiểu vẽ th
c s s các thứ thứ g s đồ thể hay S đồ cơ
sở liệu vẽ sau nhạc cung cấp đấy mình sẽ
làm việc với nhà cung cấp ở đây sẽ có
một thằng là nhà cung cấp
mình sẽ nối thằng này với cái bin đấy có
bin Ok
việc nhập không biết là đâu nhập thì có
bin rồi xuất thì có b
năng đây thường là mình sẽ vẽ cái này là
dựa trên một cái tính năng gì gì đó mình
sẽ cho đây
là nhập đi Đấy sau Tí làm tính năng xuất
sau
mấy cái tính năng này nó sẽ chỉ g liên
quan mới kiểu như này thôi đấy Kiểu kiểu
như này vại hàng TH nó cũng chẳng cần
luôn cái loại hàng thì nó sẽ ghi trong
cái thằng này này là loại hàng
đ loại loại thôi đấy thể loại đúng không
vân vân đấy Có gì nữa
xuất
rồi Ủa
Alo trang trang Tinh
à Kệ đi Delete đi d Kate chính cái này
ra CH dễ xuất
này thẳng lần này không có nhà cung cấp
nữa mình sẽ có thằng này là phiếu xất
đúng không phiếu
xuất
các thứ các thứ thì cái này cái nào
chẳng có đúng
gì nữa đâu
nhỉ chẳng còn gì đâu Nếu mà kiểu vẽ theo
kiểu vẽ theo kiểu dạng là
UK theo như tôi nhớ thì nó sẽ chỉ thế
này v cái phần tính năng tính năng UK là
theo từng tính năng nhá Đấy tính năng
nhập này thì có quản lý liên quan hàng
hóa thể loại kiểu loại hàng này tạo ra
cái bên Line này đấy cũng có thời gian
các thứ thứ xong rồi dựa theo nhà cung
cấp để cung cấp các thứ nữa thậm chí là
mình còn Thậm chí mình lưu lưu lại cái
nhà cung cấp này à Nó có những loại hàng
Hàng hóa nào chính xác là
thế Chính xác là thế nghĩa là gọi
nhá phân biệt nhá giống như ở công ty
tôi làm ấy bên tôi làm việc cũng có nhà
cung cấp cũng có sub là nhà cung cấp các
thử thử thì tôi sẽ phân biệt là mình tận
dụng vào trong chính cái bảng Hàng hóa
này nghĩa là
sản sản phẩm
nhưng mà đây Ừ nếu mà làm đơn giản nếu
mà Làm tối giả thì thực ra là mình chỉ
cần lưu lại trong chính cái hàng hóa này
là thuộc cái mình sẽ có mã nhà cung cấp
ở đây đây là nhà cung cấp ở đây này
nghĩa là mình biết được là hàng hóa này
nghĩa là nếu mà Làm tối giản nhá là ví
dụ là ông nhập sữa chẳng hạn ông chỉ có
thể nhập sữa của nhà cung cấp này thôi
đấy ví dụ là nhập sữa TH ch hay nhập sữa
Ông Thọ chẳng hạn không chỉ nhập ngỗi
của nhà công cấp này thôi còn ở công ty
tôi thì một sản phẩm có nhiều có thể có
nhiều nhà cung cấp thì nó còn khó hơn
nếu mà ông làm th ciểu đơn giản thì nó
chỉ có một thôi thì thì chính là cái đấy
nó sẽ nối lên đây này Đấy thế là xong
Thế thôi mặt hàng có hạ sử dụng nên phải
quản lý theo lô hàng lưu trữ theo quản
lý cả tránh tồn kho quá lâu Ok anh hiểu
cái này Thực ra thì về cái hạ sử dụng
theo từng cái sản phẩm hàng hóa đúng
không Ý em là thế đúng không hạ sử dụng
đây đúng
chư thì nó dựa
trên Nếu mà dựa trên theo lô đúng
đây lô này chẳng
hạn
D dựa trên theo lô Đúng
không quản lý bán hàng cà phê kiểu mang
về thì bạn gì khó chc ra chuẩn là cũng
có đấy Chẳng qua nó không làm gắt lắm
thôi
Ờ lô gọi như nhỉ Nếu mà lô mà cùng một
hạn sử dụng cũng được đây vẫn thì nó vẫn
cái ý anh á thì cái bài toán ở đây nó
vẫn dừng lại ở cái mức mức này này mức
gọi là như nào nhỉ tính năng thì nó sẽ
chỉ như này còn việc lưu của mình lưu
vào trong DB ấy thì mình sẽ tách dần ra
tính năng thì nó sẽ chỉ này đúng không
vần dừng dừng ở nhập với xất đúng chứ
Đấy sau đó thì mình tiếp theo mình mới
làm sâu hơn là kiểu à
đây copy như này
nhá mình nói về bên nhập trước nhá rõ
ràng là bỏ bỏ thằng quản lý đi
này
AD up thế quản lý vừa rồi nối hàng hóa
sai đấy quản lý phải nối đến cái thằng
này này đợi đợi ch tí Đấy phải như này
này nhà công cấp đưa hàng hóa xong ngồi
quản lý nhận nó qua cái bên LINE đó Phả
như này Đấy quản lý phải lưu như này mới
đúng này Đấy lỗi tôi lỗi tôi hơi loạn
đây phải như này
này tao
Ơ
ơ À
cho đỡ Nga
mắt đây sẽ như
này tôi làm việc với ông qua cái bên
đúng không đấy ok chưa
ạ
này Hàng hóa này tôi làm việc với ông
qua B L B L có những mặt hàng như này đó
Ok thì đấy sẽ là đúng
nhỉ đúng không
tí Đợi tôm một tí Đợi tôm một tí à không
Bin LINE nó vẫn chứa những cái mặt hàng
hóa này đợi tôi một tí nhá Đợi tôi một
tí tôi đang load
th tôi sẽ hình dung ra cái database nhá
database thì mình có số lượng các thứ
thứ số lượng này
Thể loại này thể loại nó là thể loại
hàng hóa các thứ có một bảng riêng ở đây
tôi cứ bỏ qua lại nhá nhạc cung cấp này
nhà cung cấp thì nó sẽ bản chất là nó
thêm một cái thằng một thằng nữa ở trên
này nó là nhà cung cấp đúng không nó
thực ra nó cũng dễ hiểu
nhiều nhà cung cấp để xem xem
nào một hàng hóa nhiều nhà cung cấp thì
nó sẽ phải qua b l này
thật là b
hàng hóa Chỉ bởi một nhà cung cấp Còn
nếu mà vẽ theo kiểu là nhà cung cấp nối
với Bin Line như này
thì thì rõ ràng là một hàng hóa có thể
cung cấp bởi nhiều nhiều nhà cung cấp
đấy Quan trọng là em muốn như nào rõ
ràng ở đây anh đang đọc thì có vẻ
là một loại hàng chỉ một nhà cung cấp
đảm nhiệm loại hàng nó đúng không Mình
sẽ có loại hàng ở
ạ lập trình web loại hàng này Đấy như
này
đây sẽ
có đây thì nó sẽ là trên như này Đấy sau
loại hàng đây sẽ là loại hàng đúng không
Ok Ok chưa đy Đây mã loại hàng nhá tiếp
theo số lượng đ như không thể vứt ở
trong này được số lượng từ trong chính
cái
b Đây là mối quan hệ nhiều Nhiều này tôi
vẽ mối quan hệ l nhiều nhiều cho đây mấy
ông
Ờ cái đấy là cái gì nhở đây phải đúng
rồi đúng rồi đây nó nhiều nhiều nghĩa là
à đâu một Hoàng
Hóa thuộc nhiều bên la đúng rồi Đúng
Đúng rồi nhiều nhiều đâ nh nhiều nhiều
many to many
này
load nhà cung cấp khi mà khí bên
hóa đúng một hàng hóa thuộc một loại
hàng đúng trở nhiệm thì rõ ràng là thì
đương nhiên thì tất cả một nhà cung cấp
nó là thuộc nhiều nó chữ nhiệm một loại
hàng xong rồi loại hàng đấy nó sẽ
đây nó sẽ có mã nhà cung cấp ở đây này
mã nhà cung cấp đấy Xong rồi một loại
hàng có nhiều hàng hóa đấy Đúng mà đấy
Tôi đang băn khoăn cái này thôi đó là
Bin Line này nó lưu lại nó lưu lại phải
là nó lưu lại mã nhà cung cấp thì đương
nhiên mình sẽ cần ký ký với nó đúng
không kiểu kiểu như này
này mình sẽ ký với nó là cái mã nhà cung
cấp các thứ thứ mã nhà cung cấp
phải có ký chứ Đấy ký cả mã của quản lý
mà Xác nhận các thứ thứ cái đơn này
nữa nhưng mà cái b này nó nối với thằng
hàng hóa lại qu mã hàng hóa Ừ ừ vẫn đúng
vẫn không sai đấy xong rồi mình và cái
bine này sẽ có cả hạ Sử dụng luôn này
Đấy B này lúc lúc mà Lư lại cái theo lô
mà đúng không theo Vừa nãy bảo bảo theo
lô chính là theo từng cái bine này này
là chuẩn nhất này Đấy nó sẽ chỉ ngắn gọn
này thôi đấy có số lượng nữa đúng không
Ok số lượng nữa số lượng
này loại à mã hàng hóa này Đấy nó có hết
ở trong cái bine này Đấy nó phải như này
này hóa đơn chi tiết bine chi tiết của
ông ấy đấy từ đấy mình sẽ có mình sẽ có
database thôi thôi Cái này n mình sẽ có
đấy mã quản lý có rồi mã quản lý này mã
nhà cung cấp này Đấy h sử dụng này số
lượng Ok đúng đúng đúng
rồi thì cái này mình sẽ có database là
kiểu
new new
này mã nhà cung cấp
này mã quản lý này gì gì đó đúng không
Đấy sau đó thì b l chi tiết này mình sẽ
có mã bên l mã hàng hóa số lượng hạ sử
dụng Đấy thế là xong Thế được rồi đấy
đúng R đây thì mỗi cái lô này nếu mà
trong cùng lô đ như cùng hạn sử dụng
đúng không một cái lần bên nhập về thì
chắc chắn là số
thường là hạ sử dụng nó phải giống hệt
nhau không có thằng này nửa tẻ nửa nạc
gì gì đó thì cái bảng hàng hóa thì sẽ
chỉ là lưu thông tin của sản phẩm thôi
còn để biết được là sản phẩm nào sắp hết
hạn các thứ thứ phải nối sang bên nối
sang bên live để mà biết được từng lô
từng lô các thứ thứ hạ sử dụng mọi thứ
đang như th nào em hiểu chưa
nhỉ Alo Hiểu
không
xuất thì cái này đơn giản rồi Chỉ đơn
giản xuất ra thôi gì đâu Cái này không
còn số lượng nữa quên dựa dựa vào mấy
cái chữa vừa rồi thì cái này không có số
lượng nữa chỉ có mã loại hàng thôi xuất
ra các thứ thứ thời gian như nào Cái bên
cái bên xuất thì chắc là dễ hơn ch em
hiểu nhỉ đúng không
Cập nhật lại số lượng
thừa mình mình thực ra thích thì mình có
thể lưu lại số lượng và trong và trong
cái bảng Hàng hóa nó vẫn đúng số lượng
kiểu hiện tại còn trong kho Mình lưu lại
trong trong này cái số lượng số số lượng
tồn
ấy số lượng
tồn còn trong kho thì vẫn đúng nhưng mà
ý tôi là chuẩn ấy nếu mà nếu mà nếu mà
nối từ bên la về cái binl chi tiết này
mình sẽ biết được số lượng K méo hạn sử
dụng để biết được là cần tống cái hàng
hàng nào đi chứ nếu mà các bạn chỉ lưu
mỗi số lượng thôi ví dụ là kìa Thì mình
sẽ không hề biết được là cái những cái
bao nhiêu thằng đang sắp hết hạn đúng
không Ông chỉ lưu số lượng chươ chung mà
đúng không nên là chuẩn nhất thì vẫn là
ông nên lưu số lượng kèm theo hạn sử
dụng mà như thế thì ông Chỉ ông lưu ở
trong DB vỡ mồm luôn về Nó là một nhiều
thì ông làm sao ông lưu lại được vào
trong
cái hàng hóa được ông phải lưu ông lưu
ông lấy từ trong chính cái bên live chi
tiết này ra này để ông ông kiểu xuất ra
được cái danh sách sản phẩm kèm với cái
hạ sử dụng của nó đúng không Sao anh
không ch xài chom à Tôi nói chung là gần
đây Tôi muốn chuyển qua dùng hết mấy cái
mới để cho nó cũng kiểu thử thách bản
thân một tí em hiểu đ này không
đúng nó sẽ dựa số lượng tồn đúng
không đợi anh một tí Đợi anh tí nhá Ừ em
nói câu đấy Hay anh mới đị cái đấy
thì thực ra ấy Thực ra ấy nó không nối
đến hàng hóa
đâu Tuy là nó nối hàng hóa theo kiểu
nghiệp vụ này thôi thực ra là hàng hóa
này nó là hàng hóa tuần kho phải ghi rõ
nó là như
thế tức là sao nghĩa là bản chất là phải
có phải có nhập đã rồi mới có xuất để
anh xem
[âm nhạc]
bảng hàng hóa chi tiết à để mình lưu lại
cái số lượng và sử dụng nà xem
Mình vẫn phải có một cái bảng Bảng hàng
hóa chi tiết
nhiêu để mình còn biết mình xất ra chứ
mỗi lần mình thống kê là mình sẽ à mỗi
lần mình mỗi lần mình làm cái thống kê
gì đó mình phải join rất nhiều bảng và
xăm lại cái này thì để group bu theo mã
hàng hóa thì mình lấy được số lượng còn
tồn Thực ra vẫn làm được cái
đấy
xem chuẩn là như thế nếu mà em muốn làm
database chuẩn là em vẫn phải cứ mỗi lần
em lấy số lượng tồn em phải lấy theo B
chi tiết để em group by theo cái mã hàng
hóa thì em lấy ra được số lượng còn tồn
sau đó thì em em hiển thị ra ở giáo diện
thôi chứ mình không lưu ở đâu cả là số
lượng tồn còn là bao nhiêu hạn là bao
nhiêu để em để em xuất ra và khi xuất ra
thì mình mình sẽ về sau muốn lấy lại số
lượng tồn nữa thì em sẽ lấy số lượng
group 3 như này xong em join với bảng
xất để mà em trừ đi trừ đi số lượng tôn
Nếu mà em muốn làm theo kiểu DB chuẩn nó
sẽ là thì nó là lấy
tổng số lượng
nhập trừ đi tổng số lượng xuất thì chẳng
C ra số lượng tồn đúng
không đấy thì thế thôi Nếu mà em làm đ
kiểu DB
bởi vì mình phải luôn thống kê lại còn
nếu mà em muốn lưu lại để em đỡ phải
thống kê lại ấ thì em phải có một bản
hóa đ Bản kiểu hoàng hóa chi tiết và và
bản chất Ấy bản chất ấ nó là thiết kế
database không chuẩn Không chuẩn hóa Thế
nào là chuẩn Hóa chuẩn Hóa là những cái
gì mà có thể tính toán được dựa trên cái
d liệu khác ấy thì mình không nên lưu nó
lại một khi mình lưu nó lại như thế thì
nó là bất quy tắc chuẩn Bởi vì nó có thể
sai số nghĩa là cái kia bị sửa mà cái
không được sửa thì nó sẽ là gây ra sai
số em hiểu không nghĩa là chuẩn là mình
phải luôn thống kê lại đây giống như này
lấy số lượng nhập trừ đi số lượng
xất không thực ra không quan tâm đến cái
lô đâu em trong trường hợp này đâu liên
quan đến lô
đâu Anh đâu nói về hạ sử dụng đâu anh
chỉ cũng không liên quan đến cái b Line
nào mà tổng tổng tất cả các tổng tất cả
dựa theo bảng bine chi tiết này này thì
lấy được số lượng tổng số lượng của cái
hàng hóa đấy ví dụ ở ở đây là sữa đúng
không sữa Ông Thọ đúng không Đấy nó có
tận đây sữa Ông Thọ Đây là 5 đây là đây
là 10 đi thì tổng nó chả 15 đúng không
đấy thì tổng tổng nhập vào là 15 đúng
chưa Không Quan Tâm mãi B 1 2 đấy không
quan tâm tổng nó vẫn là 15 đấy Sau đó
thì em thì về sau em có một cái là biế
la xuất chẳng hạn đấy Đấy giả sử thế đấy
mình sẽ có số lượng suất là bao là 10 số
lượng xất là bao
nhiêu là năm Hơi chẳng hạn thì em sẽ lấy
trừ trừ đi thì nói chung là luôn phải
thống kê lại đấy Kiểu như thế đấy Làm
kiểu database chuẩn thiết kế kiểu chuẩn
đặc biệt là ở trường nữa thì càng không
không thực tế nghĩa là chỉ là phải làm
chuẩn hóa phải làm theo đ lý thuyết làm
theo thực tế thì đúng là để cho mình đỡ
phải thống kê lại mỗi lần gọi đến là
mình phả thống kê lại ấ thì mình thường
ấy có lưu lại nhưng mà nó sẽ không chuẩn
hóa thì anh nghĩ là ở trường mình sẽ làm
theo lý thuyết em
cho bạn này rồi Có gì anh
cứ
cứ thử export cái này ra để cho em tham
khảo
này quản lý kho đúng
không đ load
đúng không DB
xịn lắm Nó copy cái này nó sẽ biến thành
Google shit cơ kiểu thành cái shit ấy
bây giờ nó bị kiểu dạng in là như này h
trước nó thành kiểu copy past kiểu này
nó thành shit hay phết kiểu thành cái
ảnh ấy thính ra là thế thành cái ảnh ấy
chứ không phải Google sheet đâu thành
cái ảnh
các thứ thứ trông nó đẹp hơn
thôi chứ cũng cũng tham khảo thôi mà có
cóp được cái gì đâu ok
nhỉ Hôm này 1 tiếng rưỡi rồi định định
tâm sự xong rồi chữa thêm nhiều cái nữa
Nhưng có vẻ là muộn rồi
Ờ mấy câu hỏi này chắc
là
có các bạn cứ hỏi ở trên cái link của
mình để mình trả lời dần nhá Chắc là hôm
nay cứ tạm nghỉ đã
nhỉ Ok chào mấy ông tôi nghỉ tôi lấy sức
mai còn đi
dậy OK Chào mấy ông nhé Bye